[Music]
I love the show
all right my name is headed by hello i
pewdiepie whatever he's a funny funny
brit guy I'm obviously a Swedish person
she must be a pro she knows Swedish it's
okay I get it elders you don't like
Megan Fox done it's not like you can do
it better I'm a surgeon oh yeah they
played this in an episode be what they
actually got it oh my god they actually
like he needs help Jesus Freak what is
the duck only the prophecy will tell oh
this guy really hates me huh huge it's a
very good title for this hole thank you
that she wants to pee on me well at
least let me take my shirt off I'm a
subscribe to that that was a barrel off
a volley you knew ladies so what exactly
was he doing in these videos hates me
thinking he's way cooler than everybody
else why is this so mean I like him he's
funny also I'd smack his face if he
walked in here oh say why is tell you
why those are those insert shots of the
duck everyone so often that would pop up
you like the duck all right to death the
duck should I narrated the whole thing
he's on to us
but the commentary absolutely made up
for whatever was actually going on in
the video
these ladies awesome like trying to
understand this so you're watching
somebody else doing and instead of doing
it yourself what is the purpose of that
what did you just enjoy the games
yourself well I don't know if you
haven't heard of sports it's been around
for maybe a couple thousand years it
might be a little too old for you it's
funny all right it's healthy it's good
stuff
this guy's awesome it's intriguing to
see someone else deal with maybe the
frustration or deal with the joy you
know of doing something well or not see
they kind of get it and they're not bad
but again if it's not something positive
it shouldn't exist then why do you exist
so Puri pie is real name is Felix and
he's from Sweden that's the trouble I've
never known anybody from Sweden I still
don't understand what's so weird about
Swedish people right here again right
you're totally normal
oh how many YouTube subscribers do you
think PewDiePie has no he actually is
the number one most subscribed person on
YouTube get out of here I have it
Kleenex
it makes me want to cry that this is
what we are as I go you can now buy that
you cheese adorable girls get big
crushes oh stop it a lot of people get
very upset that video game commentating
has become so popular because they think
there's no work that goes into it what
do you think about that well to me it's
no talent I consider that no talent
whatsoever to sit there make snide
comments about anything so what exactly
are you doing right now then I don't
think you can make that statement
these guys are comedians and that's why
it's not the game hey this guy knows
what's up cutie pie calls his fan base
the bro army are you going to join the
bros nope he's part of the Ducks of
course not brofist yeah brofist what are
you pay
nope wait how much do you want sorry guy
I know it's only a matter of time they
will all join us these guys like old
Phil Dunphy or something I love it well
that would better than expected alright
I hope you enjoyed this episode
obviously not all these elders were too
into my videos and that's totally fine
my videos are not for everyone and I
never expected that but I do see far too
often people in the comments arguing
over it and it just seems really
unnecessary everyone is entitled to
their opinion of course and no one
should be harassed for it but if someone
is being an ass over having an opinion
which happens a lot on the internet then
please just ignore us you would be doing
me a great favor with the the kind of
popularity I have right now on the
Internet I get people trying to throw
[ __ ] at me everyday and I'm just so done
caring about it I appreciate that you
bros trying to stand up for me sometimes
but really I wish you bros wouldn't care
as well
that being said thank you bros so much
for watching my videos it really the
fact that you enjoy it and support it is
the reason why I enjoy making it so
thank you stay awesome bros I know you
will
[Music]
you